como una obsesión me encanta me encanta
estar al lado del agua el hecho de estar
dentro lado en un kayak tan finito
es muy lindo creo que lo que me pudo
haber atrapado en primera instancia
empecé a los 12 años que son como un
juego como cualquier deporte y la
disciplina me gustó sigo con el dinero
de cada merienda que me daban para
comprar algo en la tarde
si me alquilaba un kayak así que voy a
con hambre
y estar tantos tantas horas
entrenamiento diarias que permite
conocerte
y también te ayuda para el día a día
para un montón de cosas uno conversa con
uno mismo muchísimo y se auto analiza
y eso está buenísimo
tuve comida en julio del año pasado me
afectó más el tiempo de estar parado las
dos semanas sin entrenar que el virus en
sí no no no creo que ellos eso me haya
afectado porque lo cruce de manera
asintomática
la verdad que representar el país para
mí es un orgullo tremendo es
inexplicable no pienso en un resultado
determinado sueño con una medalla en los
últimos tres campeonatos del mundo en
dos estuvo en final entonces estar en
una final de un juego olímpico creo que
se puede pensar tranquilamente y si
logras tener una final de un juego
olímpico puedo soñar con una de as
sacrificio obviamente que hay que hacer
pero bueno en función de lo que uno ama
y de un objetivo es como que no me gusta
llamarlo como tal